hi everyone it's jerry i'd like to share
a game with you from the most recent
season of the top chess engine
championship
so this is the game between leela
chastero and stockfish
season 21 super final
game 71 of their 100 game match
i've been staring at this game for what
feels like close to 10 hours now not all
in one sitting but with my own engine
experimenting
just found this one more and more
interesting tested out a lot of
different variations
this video will be
much more than me simply showing the
moves of a game
i feel that i grew as a player
and maybe by this video's end if you're
sticking around for it all
you two can benefit
these top chess engine championship
games are some of the highest quality
games you'll find they're not always
easy to wrap one's head around
i don't quite get that impression with
this particular game because
well i believe this is largely the case
because of the central structure
it's a static one
and
as a result there really isn't a wide
variety of moves to be choosing from
throughout
comes off as a more strategic game
a battle of plans
now this last move bishop g4 is what
denotes the samajin variation of the
king's indian defense
after d5 and knight a5 this is where
game 71 began
this is where the engines are now on
their own
before i
look at what is played next
i'd like to touch on
this particular move that's
in at least one of the databases
it's been played thousands of times and
it's not good
bishop captures knight
the reply bishop captures bishop has
been played over a thousand times that
reply is also not good
uh
why is that well
it's because after knight to e5 there's
white experience is a problem on c4
c4 by the way in this game is the main
focal point there will be a lot of
pressure applied to it and white will
need to react properly
how do you defend c4 in this position
well if you try b3
and you run in white would be running
into these tricks
and there's a problem on this diagonal
so
also if white
tries to babysit the pawn with a queen
that runs into knight f to d7
looking to next kick the queen away and
then maybe win the pawn outright
and there's even a
line i stumbled upon where
if the queen gets greedy well she's
gonna get
hunted
here's a quick
queen trap for you
she's dead
okay my point here is that capturing on
f3 with the bishop is not good
because white can recapture with the
pawn
this is not a deficiency for white to
have the doubled pawns
it's nice to have e2 vacant for the
queen now
knight e5 or knight a5
queen could go here
and this pawn could even look forward to
going to
f4
open up the bishop's eyes in that way
and control e5 from all minor pieces
while not compromising the king side
structure at all
right
if it's the f2 pawn going to f4 and
there's the e pawn still around you're a
bit more weakened on your second rank
not the case here
okay
knight a5 the first move of this game is
b3
this is how white's defending c4 now
just a moment ago
i was pointing out some tricks against
the
the knight and the rook
there are no good tricks in this
particular position i know i've been in
this
uh very position before as white in some
blitz or bullet games and i've shied
away from playing b3 because i thought
there would be a problem here on the
diagonal
there is not a problem
this trick is not working here
because we can take the knight with our
knight
and after bishop takes rook we have
bishop d2 a very nice double attack
against the knight in bishop
and soon white will be playing a
position
up two minor pieces versus the rook
completely winning for white
what's played c5
and from here bishop g5
in
many of the
um
human games that i've had a look at from
this opening
i saw that the bishop was eventually
deployed to b2
it's not a bad move
but
the bishop is a bit
more vulnerable on b2
instead of g5
and why do i think this well
it's because
this is the side of the board the queen
side where black will be playing
black will be striving for b5
black has the furthest advanced pawn on
c5 and every furthest advanced pawn
likes to have a pawn right next to it
similarly
this guy will one day like to have this
guy right next to it
duos are strong in the game
this is where black wants to play where
they have space this is the space this
is the space
and once the b files opened you could
see that the rook will be however
indirect
maybe directly
putting pressure on the b2 point so in
this game it goes to g5 not
with the intention to one day give up
the bishop for knight
in the game we had a6
if questioned
we're not doing this we're not giving up
the bishop for knight
instead white would be falling back to
d2 in fact the initial deployment to d2
was also a
a very strong move as well instead of
going to g5
uh
if if h6 is in and the bishop goes back
to d2 white is in a way saying aha
your bishop on g7 now has a
responsibility you can't go too far i
might just swipe that h6 pawn to
illustrate not making the very best
moves here but the quickest way to show
that there's a restriction placed on
this guy
this typical maneuver of the king knight
sweeping into e5 well now you can't
recapture with the piece can you there
goes the h6 pawn so something needs to
be done with h6 before black can make
some maneuver like that
okay in the game black carries on with
queen side play
prep work for b5
h3 and there are several bishop moves
that i would like to touch on here
um
first one is the capture
we've seen it before
this would be the way to recapture
in in the game the bishop goes back home
but yeah if this were once more taking
with the pawn
it's nice to have this it's also nice to
have this square for the bishop to
secure c4
again there's going to be some pressure
on that point soon enough
okay
and if it goes here well it's dead after
g4
let's have a look at this one
bishop d7
this is if the bishop is posted on d7
uh at first glance this move says to me
ah okay you're you're supporting this
b5 push but
now d7 is not opened up for the knight
and so what this means is white's
central push of e4 and e5 will hit that
much harder
black wants to be in a spot to meet e4
with knight d7
controlling
this quick e5 break so bishop on d7
doesn't allow for that
one other variation let's say the bishop
goes to f5
this is one of the more human-like moves
this is prep work for knight e4
i really liked experimenting with this
particular move because
i got to see a
a pretty slick
reply by white here i really like this
next move
in reply to bishop f5 you ready for this
one
not all that common
queen e1
now the first thought that ran through
my mind is oh okay the queen on e1 what
what is she doing she's supporting e4
but there's an additional point the
queen has some function along this
diagonal she observes the knight on a5
and i'll be highlighting a variation
where there's
uh there can be a problem on that square
so
how do first of all how does black stop
the e4 push
if you
you just make some rook move or you
continue to go for this e4 is in there
and
what what do you do here there's knight
takes knight knight takes knight
bishop takes rook now there's this nice
move knight takes pawn taking advantage
of the pin
and then he could take the bishop next
white is winning this
it's already reading as a plus five
so let's say instead of
instead of rook to b8 let's say the
knight hops in straight away once more
we can have this trick
if bishop takes rook we have knight
takes d6
i'll carry it out a few more moves
because we get to see
we get to see queen e1 for a second time
white right here is ready to get the
piece back with bishop h6 if that's shut
down with f6
once more we could have the queen go to
e1 from a1 this time hitting the knight
and supporting e4
uh black is basically dead
this position is really really bad this
knight is clueless and these rooks are
staring at each other asking
what are we supposed to do
there's absolutely no play here for team
black
okay anyhow this
this is a pretty slick move queen to e1
also important to know
is that when you make this queen e1 move
you need to be prepared to play a
position type where you're down the
exchange
and
it involves this guy being exchanged for
the rook so let me highlight this
move once more and instead of taking the
rook straight away let's say bishop
takes knight is on board
they would follow rook c1 and now if
this bishop goes hunting for the rook
it's okay to allow your rook to be
captured by the dark square bishop the
key defender for the black king side
white could pursue an attack against the
king with h4
let's say black carries on with this
play on the queen side
and here's a slick variation
right here say rick b8
look at this one
i'm highlighting this particular line
because it's a nice way to demonstrate
the weaknesses of the dark squares
about that move hits the queen
and threatens a mate
in
two
okay anyhow want to give some sense as
to how we could be coping with this
knight plant on e4 queen e1 it's a
really good move here
all right
in the game it was the bishop going all
the way back home
e4 on board black doesn't want to see e5
so knight d7
white gets off the diagonal
and
well gets off the diagonal supports the
knight and supports
c4 white is anticipating this pressure
on the c4 pawn
and from here we have b5 pop quiz
how will how would you react to the b5
move
feel free to pause the video
okay uh in the computer's eyes
the top suggestion is to grab the pawn
like this
but if you do this you're
basically
going to have to play
down the exchange
it still says it's better for white but
yeah this follow-up move a bishop to a6
black has some nice play on the queen
side
and is soon going to be getting the rook
he could defend the knight but this is
way way way too weakened
if
black simply regains the pawn
yeah this is this is an excellent
position for black so
uh white would have to play this one
and
i don't know it's not the same as the
earlier
uh shared variation where
white was down the exchange and it was
the dark square bishop that was
uh
given up for for the rook
it's the light square bishop given up
for the rook here so not as clear
uh the approach taken by leela is a very
instructive one in his
uh one of the main
uh
this this was this is one of the main
moves that first grabbed my attention
about this game
to not go ahead and grab on v5
and instead make a defensive move
uh
what is this defensive move queen d3
there she goes move 14 and
there she will stay
until move 34.
it is the first of
uh several defensive moves set several
defensive moves that white will be
playing in this game
and it will seem like black has some
initiative
because there's some pressure being
applied to c4 but eventually
that pressure
you know there's only so much pressure
that could be applied to c4 and once
it's neutralized
black runs out of
productive moves
so this is a nice controlled approach
to simply secure c4
and by securing c4 you stay rock solid
on d5 your most important pawn d5
that's going nowhere
okay
the approach here is rook b8
bishop d2 so voluntarily
dropping the bishop back to d2 where it
observes the b4 square
white's anticipating the rook will be
pivoting there wants to take that square
away from the rook
something i questioned right around this
point here is
when i saw b5
i i saw the reply was queen to d3
and i questioned well
instead of
instead of this b5 move
suppose
suppose black plays h6 now
are we still going to drop back to d2
uh if the bishop's on d2 and then b5 is
played you know now we can't get to d3
in one move is that going to bother us
what would we do there
so i i want to highlight how
we can be following up if h6 is flicked
in there and the bishop is on d2
and only then b5 is in
uh how's this for a move you ready
knight e2
and now we have this
idea to me b take c
with the recapture straight away
or we could even consider
queen to e1
and we get to see this battery towards
a5
really playing an excellent role in the
game
once more this queen on e1 is
uh
one of those aesthetic moves i just
really like the queenie one move
now what does black do
uh if the knight has to fianchetto
this was the side of the board black was
supposed to be playing on something has
clearly gone way wrong for team black
also
so if this is on board if the knight has
to go to b7 black is dead this is not
the way to play something's definitely
gone wrong
similarly
if let's say rook b8 is in
we can also have queenie one and this is
even worse
right the the rook can't even see the
knight is there or even let's say if
it's shut down with b4
now how do you even play in the queen
side you have to undo all your moves
knight has to retreat rook has to come
back over a5 a4
finally you get a break but you're
probably going to be getting killed in
just a few moves on the king on the king
side somehow
these these brakes with e5
it's not the way to go so the main point
is this battery of the queen and bishop
can be super super effective in
neutralizing black's
play on the queen side
okay
b5 on board queen d3 rook b8
bishop d2 voluntarily
chop chop rook b4
let me back up
after rook to b4 so we had knight d1
yeah this
this maneuver right here is pretty neat
the rook is there to defend the knight
has an eye on e3 the rook is hit
i had a test
i wanted to test out a different move by
the rook
and
this one right here how how are we
reacting if the rook goes to b2 is a
question i had
the proper way to react to rook b2 is to
challenge the rook right away
and then i
my eyes were opened some
after this this move right here because
instinctually
my
recapture you know what's what's the
natural way to recapture you take with
the rook and say aha
there's only one open file and i control
it
there's a problem with that
and it's that this knight can now get to
b6
and how are you defending c4 you're not
so
if the rook went to the second rank
instead of b4
you challenge it and then you're
prepared to recapture with the knight
and now this is opening up the bishop
to ca5 so there is no knight b6 you
would take the knight
again a lot of attention needs to be
given to c4
another line from this point
i questioned well suppose the queen
looks to sneak in
and put some pressure on c4 he can't do
it right now but let's say
this queen b6 move
preparing to meet knight c3 with queen
b4 this is not a good path
for team black this is a this is another
way the queen could end up getting
trapped the black queen in this case
showed an earlier one where it was the
white queen
this queen is now stuck
bishop f1 is right around the corner
um how do you save the queen it points
out you have to go here with the knight
and eventually we have this move here
knight d1 threatening the knight and
there's now two different ways to maybe
track down the queen bishop c3 or bishop
e3
so i want to give you a taste at least
for
a different pivot square by this rook
now that there's an open file there's
only two squares to cover b4 and b2
we had to look at b2 in the game rook b4
knight d1 follows
rook a4
out of the bishop's view rook c2 some
more defense
this guy's under control
by the rook
they're offsetting one another
this rook is also quite limited
doesn't have uh another square to go to
so
there's some
tricks we're gonna soon find out over
that c4 square
let's get some moves in here knight e5
knight exchange
king to h2 my initial impression of king
h2 was oh okay
white is maybe ready to play f4
and then after the reply bishop d4 it's
not hitting with check
i'm not so sure that's really the point
um
the f
f2 pawn does not get rolling
uh
so quick in this game
i came across one variation where
it points out that h4 and bishop h3 can
be an idea
so king h2 in this game
bishop d7
knight e3
and bishop to d4
and from here we have h4
now
one of the most
common moves you will find in this
position instead of h4
is
rook to b1
this is not a good move and this was one
of those
eye-opening points for me
with this game
it seems
completely sensible right there's
maybe
too much of a robotic type of thinking
on my part right one open file
control open file it's not good though
uh it's under control but only very very
temporarily is it under control
if it is the case where
the king rooks are exchanged black will
find it much easier
to have the queen enter white's house
getting into b1
exerting additional pressure on a2
the white position can easily collapse
if the white queen if the black queen
enters white's house
so white and white needs to take some
care
about this next move going to b1 is not
a good idea
let me illustrate
how this move can backfire let's say
queen c7 super sensible
ready to get to rook b8 let's say h4 is
in there
rook b8
rook exchange
let's say white swings the back
completely around with this h4 h5
engagement
with g6
uh the queen could enter right now on b1
it says even better was to capture the
knight but we get to see now that
there's this
super invasive queen
not easy to cope with this
so
we don't go to the b file
not just yet at least instead it's h4
and now we have a mysterious looking
queen to e8
queen e1 was played for white
uh in some fun variations in the actual
game
uh queen e8 is on board
took me
a little bit to make sense of queen to
e8
this post has an influence on both
sectors kingside and queenside
we'll see its influence in the game
uh
well there are some tricks on the queen
side on the king side it's
it's preventing white from playing h5
here this consistent follow-up h5 right
now would not be a good move
because black can play e5
and
the king is going to be a little bit
more vulnerable white wants to be able
to meet this potential
break with e6 or e5 with a capture
but now the queen is observing the
king's side
right after this capture
the black queen is doing pretty well
there's no longer an h pawn around for
white
and there are some checks for black none
for white currently
okay
queen e8 discourages h5
and there's some
indirect influence on the b5 square
only at this stage do we have rook b1
now just moments ago i pointed out rook
b1 it could be neutralized the black
queen could enter
it's a little bit different now
if black wants to
neutralize the rook it needs to come
a tempo down
let me first point out that if black
tries to play with e6 or e5 here
there's the reply of rook b6 we see
that the queen is no longer observing b6
rook b6 would be a good follow-up
striking
a6
a6 and d6
now suppose black
plays it attempt tempo down plays queen
to queen to a8
next up rook to b8
we can have h5 and after rook b8 you
ready for this next move
white says no
not exchanging rooks i'm going to go to
a file that will
soon
open rook h1 i just i find moves like
this really cool queenie one earlier
this move right here another case rook
h1
that's really sweet
not giving up
or giving up control the b file
and instead focusing on the soon to be
opened h file
white is going after the king here
let's say rook b6 we can have
a bishop exchange first let's say black
doubles
king g2
rook b1 another case where white could
say nope
i'm not going to exchange rooks just yet
i could i could first capture right here
and then play rook to h4
this is completely winning for white
there's the idea to exchange dark square
bishops and give checkmate on h8
yeah
white is not making it so easy for the
black queen
of all pieces to enter on b1
this this idea to form some battery is
not really a threat at all
i had a look at this variation
because it would just end up being one
check
no problem
the king can simply go to f3
yeah
it's plus 19 and climbing i think it's
soon going to read a mate
but
anyhow some some idea as to how we can
be coping with the
threat to exchange
king rooks
white should be ducking that particular
exchange
okay
from here we have bishop takes knight
and not the typical recapture
this was
another super instructive point for me
in the game we had bishop takes knight
now if we simply recapture with the
bishop
we get to see how this queen plays a
role
on the queen side from its e8 post
what is this trick
knight takes c4
rook takes knight
bishop b5 rook takes bishop queen
takes on b5
and what's going to happen with this
particular variation
is we end up with
two bishops versus
rook and pawn imbalance
it reads as a plus one for white but
this is apparently going to be a draw
with best play
bishop takes pawn could be met with rook
b4
looking next at rook a4
a drawn position you'll know with this
imbalance the black king does not
experience any problems he's not
going to be attacked
it's a more technical position here with
this imbalance
i'm drawing attention to this
because if black tries this particular
trick on c4 one move sooner
which is to say before the queen is on
e8
um
this would not be a good choice for
team black to go in for the capture on
c4 because
this imbalance right here
two bishops versus rook and pawn well
the queens are still on board and
there is a problem with king safety
there can be some dark square issues a
break in the center
yeah
this is this is a scary position for
team black this is a this is a winning
position for white with the queens on
okay
queen eight rook b1 bishop takes knight
in the game met with the atypical reply
bishop takes knight
and from here we have bishop takes f2
and
if black captures the bishop
um
well i'm sorry if if white captures this
bishop this this is what was played in
the game rook takes bishop and rook
takes bishop but i had a question for
myself at this stage
uh
why doesn't
white
go ahead and win the pawn
back currently whites down upon
white could win the pawn back
with the move bishop c3
there's only one reply here
bishop d4 the only way to save the
bishop
and this is how white could win the pawn
back isn't this good for white queen in
the center materials now balanced
white doesn't want to win the pawn back
why
well with this variation you'll know
that black
the pawn that white won
was the c5 pawn
white wants to keep the black c5 pawn
around
let's see why
this is really cool
um
the move played in the game rook takes
bishop
rook takes bishop
c5 is occupied by a pawn
which means this rook
is now stuck
on the edge it doesn't have access to c5
it is restricted to the a file alone
a5 a4 the only safe squares for the rook
uh black is basically playing down a
rook blacks up a pawn
but
down a rook
can only go here
that's slick
it's a you know this was a candidate for
the title to the video you know leela
traps
stockfish's rook
um
yeah this is a big problem now
okay let's see how play follows first
entering on the seventh rank
from here queen d8
if the rook is challenged with bishop c8
the rook would be maintained on the
seventh keeping pressure on e7
it's queen d8
now a3
the queen has the responsibility for
defending the pawn now which frees up
this rook to go elsewhere
normally you wouldn't want to allocate
the queen to the defense of a pawn like
this but she's not really
inconvenienced she's still
nice and central
guarding base points
why not give her another job the rooks
are going to next look to enter black's
camp
okay also an additional point i only
noticed much much later in reviewing
this game is that
in one of the variations the rook is now
you know not able to maybe one day take
the pawn on a2 and say check
okay it's on a3 now
okay from here we have bishop c8
now when the queen was on e8 i said if
bishop c8 you would maintain the rook on
the seventh rank
not the case here
we have rook b8
white looks to one day form a battery
on the eighth rank
why not rook a7 here
uh it's because black would be able to
get away with a
uh a perpetual attack against this rook
so i found this one to be pretty neat
the queen could go to b6
and allow white to give up e7
and simply return home
and we have this
this going on
here
the rook could get hunted there's some
fancy line there where it's still some
draw
even though the rook is tracked down but
yeah the main idea here is that if you
try and maintain the rook on the seventh
rank there is uh this little resource on
b6 and d8 with the black queen
so in the game
it's rook b8
queen d7 out of the pin
white doubles on the b file
and now looks to double on the eighth
rank
it's getting pretty serious for black
now
um
just a moment away now
from forming this battery and the bishop
may never
be able to move so
uh this may be the last chance for the
bishop to move but it's not a good
choice here
so
if the bishop tries to get out of
the line of fire bishop d7 that there's
a problem there
chop on f8
and then you go to c3 hitting the rook
and
threatening mate in one
game over
for black
so you can't move
bishop what's tried is g5
breaking down the king side structure
eliminate the h pawn give some checks on
the h file
this is black's attempt
pawn takes queen takes
battery is formed on the eighth rank
this rook is still stuck
there's no c5 square to help out
from here we have queen h6 yeah black's
attempt in this game is to give some
checks
we eventually have a queen exchange but
one last line to
uh discuss
is a very human-like one
which is to uh
let's say
defend
c8 like this queen g4 i want to give you
an idea how you can
how white can be reacting to such a move
uh
i found this to be one of the the
cleaner approaches queen f3
if there's a queen exchange this bishop
will soon fall so the queen needs to
stick around defending the bishop
and if the queen is on d7 now we have
this move e5
looking to maybe open up this diagonal
if there's this capture this pawn has
the ability to move
if black doesn't react to this move at
all let's say passes
we can break down the light squares with
e6
and what does black do here
if there's a capture
we can take the bishop
and then we can capture on e6
queen takes e6 there's bishop h3
that stings
yeah that's there's there's no good
solution here for black
some other variation
let's consider
um instead of this passing move rook a4
suppose black captures
why can follow up with once more a
capture on c8
and then
bishop to h3
if queen takes bishop king takes queen
rook takes rook
d6
hitting the rook in this guy's past one
way or the other
no good solution here for black
this imbalance queen and pawn queen and
pass pawn versus two disconnected rooks
yeah
the rooks are no match for the queen and
past pawn
if here we can take
um
yeah if here guarding all seventh ring
squares we can push
we have also this g4 check
so no good solution for team black with
that variation and one last one to look
at
is after e6 we can take the rook
take on e6
and then play queen f6
there's a problem on e6 and there's no
solution
okay
queen g4 not tried in this game
instead we had a check on h6
c1
that's blocked queen e3 check queen f2
and from here rook takes a3
if more checks followed with let's say
queen c1 the bishop would block
there are no follow-up checks and the
queen is out of position to defend the
bishop
white will soon be winning the bishop
so again what is tried rook takes a3 and
we enter
uh this ending where white picks up the
bishop
the rook is free it's true but this one
is now
gonzo
for team black
uh what do you even try here anything
else to consider after this if you
capture c5 falls
so all white needs to do is keep a pawn
around
and this extra pawn is going to be the
g3 pawn no way for
black to exchange that
g3 pawn off
so we just have these final moves coming
in
nothing really exciting from this point
on just the conversion
past pawn gets rolling
and
a little bit of a fun way to have this
one end rook b7
brings us to a six
six piece table base win for team white
the game goes no further
and yeah that's the that's the ball game
for this game 71 so
i found this one
uh yeah
very interesting i mean to be sticking
around
for several hours staring at this one
i think i touched on most of the
variations i wanted to share
um
yeah anyhow i i i hope you took
something away from this one
uh feel free as usual to leave any
feedback in the comments section below
and that's all for now take care bye
you